reviews are in for cyberpunk 2077
Phantom Liberty and it looks like people
are pretty well loving it what keeping
in mind the reviews are also very
positive when the game originally came
out and I did not get a review code I
didn't get a review code for the
original game I didn't review it then
obviously not reviewing it now but I do
personally love this game and I'm really
excited about this expansion it is
currently sitting at an 88 on Metacritic
this is specifically for the PS5 version
actually funnily enough the other two
versions are sitting at 89 for some
reason dualshockers gave it a nine
praising the captivating story laid
characters with excellent acting
credible visuals and environments and
refined IGN also gave it a nine they
similarly praised the storytelling and
excellent performances some smarter
insights on the genre and themes in
general and much improved gameplay
thanks to the 2.0 update which of course
is free for everybody I think that's so
awesome and Gamespot gave it a full 10
out of 10. noting that the story has two
stunning yet wildly different routes and
conclusions rebuilt RPG elements that
help with combat and remarkable detail
and density in Dogtown